Here is your first foray
into iOS development,
and I'm going to start you out with
something we call control flow.
One way to control the flow of code
in our app is with an if statement.
In Swift if statements
are easy to use and
understand with a minimal
amount of code to type.
Here's how it works.
It starts with a keyword if and
then a statement that you expect to be
true, following by opening curly braces.
The closing curly braces
finish off the if.
Inside the if statement,
you can put the code that you want to
run if that statement evaluates to true.
Some say change is the only
constant thing in life.
What if we want to run some code
if the statement is not true?
Enter the else clause.
Right after the closing
curly brace of the if,
we add the keyword else and
another set of curly braces.
In there, we have code we want to run
if the statement evaluates to false.
There are other types of control flows
in Swift including a very powerful
switch statement that we will
cover later on in this Nanodegree.
In fact, we even have an elective
course called Swift Syntax that
takes you into all the ins and
outs of the Swift language.
Now let's move on to Xcode.
In Xcode open
the QuizViewController.swift file.
In project zero I've pulled out most of
the code into something we call a class
extension just so we can focus on
the few lines of code you need to write.
Scroll down until you see the @IBAction
func flagButtonPressed function.
This function is called when the user
presses one of the three flag buttons.
We need to see if the user
press the correct button and
then display a message to them.
How to do this?
An if statement will work great.
The variable that this function is
given when called is named sender.
By the way, you will hear people
use the phrase passed in.
It just means the variable sent
to a function when it is called.
Sender is an object representing
the button pressed by the user.
All buttons have an integer tag.
And we have also stored the correct tag
under the variable
called correctButtonTag.
So let me walk you through this.
We know the correct tag is stored under
a variable called correctButtonTag.
We know we just got passed an object
corresponding to the button that was
pressed as a parameter to
this function called sender.
So we need to check if the tag
of the button that is passed
is the same as the correctButtonTag.
In other words, we need to check whether
the user pressed the right button and
picked the correct language.
Here is the if statement that
you need to add to this.
The double equals is
a comparison checking to see
if the passed in buttons tag is
the same as a correctButtonTag.
If it is, great.
Tell the user they chose
the correct answer.
If the tag integer values do not line
up, the answer was incorrect, and
we should inform the user as well.
With this if statement added,
we should be able to run the app and
see what happens when
we choose an answer.